did you know that google offers plugins
for vs code and intellij and that
google cloud comes with a powerful build
tool
in this video we'll cover developing and
building with gcp tools from ides to
continuous integration and continuous
delivery
so stick around
[Music]
if you've missed the earlier episode on
developer and management tools
check out the first link in the
description as it discusses the google
cloud sdk
and tools such as cloud shell and gcloud
for those of you building applications
deployed as containers on kubernetes
such as on gke
or to cloud run and would like to spend
more time writing code instead of yaml
config files
then you should really try google cloud
code
cloud code is a set of id extensions for
vs code and
intellij that let you rapidly iterate
debug and deploy code to container
runtime such as gke
but also to other kubernetes
implementations
under the covers cloud code uses popular
tools such as scaffold
minicube jib and obviously cubectl
to provide you with continuous feedback
right inside your code editor
it also supports remote debugging of
your apps while leveraging built-in ide
debugging features as you get started
with cloud code you should try the
built-in template
that will help you create a kubernetes
application that just works
in seconds and then deploy it to
kubernetes cluster
one click but also continuous deployment
to your local kubernetes cluster
is supported via scaffold for a tight
development inner loop
you can also decide to set up your
application that runs on cloud run
using a starter template deploying your
app to cloud run
and looking at the status of your live
application's resources
cloud code will let you easily switch
between different build profiles
to build containers using your local
docker installation
or using tools like cloud build which
we'll talk about in a second
you can also edit config files with auto
completion
and linting for kubernetes all with
inline documentation
with this feature you may actually start
to like yaml
generating diffs between local and
remote config files is another neat
feature provided by the tool
cloud code lets you view and stream logs
from any of your deployments
pods and containers as well as inspect
the cluster's resources with a built-in
kubernetes explorer
this is not only about container
packaged apps but also about making the
numerous google cloud libraries
available to you as a developer straight
in the ide
it is also about supporting all types of
development artifacts
without having to build the container
images thanks to
growing support for build packs building
and deploying straight from your
development environment can be
very productive but it can also feel a
bit magical
it is also not very well aligned with
devops best practices
since it does allow for automation and
can lead to errors due to different
build environments in order to decouple
the build
and deploy process from your development
tools
gcp offers cloud build a fully managed
ci cd platform
that executes your builds on google
cloud platform infrastructure
cloud build typically requires a build
config file
a set of instructions expressed in json
or yaml
describing what tasks need to be
performed
or simply a docker file you can
configure bills to
fetch dependencies to run unit tests
static analysis
and integration tests you can also
create artifacts
with build tools such as docker gradle
maven
and bazel and finally you can also
deploy these artifacts to your preferred
runtime or artifact repository
cloud build executes your build as a
series of steps
each executed in a docker container that
is provided by cloud build
by the community or by yourself google
provides and maintains pre-built images
called builders
that you can reference in your build
steps to execute your tasks
builds are kicked off using the gcloud
cli the cloud build api
or via some pre-configured source
repository
hosted on github or a bitbucket
in fact cloudbill provides a github app
which uses github events to
automatically invoke builds
on github pushes and pull requests and
view your build results
on github and cloud console all with
cmos authentication
as part of a build container images can
be created and pushed to google cloud
registry
and applications can be continuously
deployed to compute engine
to kubernetes engine to cloud functions
or to cloud run
cloud build does not need to be about
app source code
cloud build can be used in conjunction
with infra as code tools
such as hashicorps terraform or with
third-party developer tools such as
jfrog's artifactory
now that you have a truly versatile
build ncicd tool and plugins for popular
ids what are you waiting for
i really can't wait to see what you code
and build with gcp
if you like this video please like
subscribe comment share
and look forward to more google cloud
essentials videos
[Music]
you